you put out a list of the dumbest
mistakes that guys make on the first
three dates and I want to go through
these the first one was they're way too
shy and stick to surface level talk
so many guys are trying to give the
woman a fun experience and that's not
what women who are looking for
commitment are looking for they're not
they're tired of the fun they are tired
of just having endless people dancing
for them that's not really what they
want they want substance but they're
afraid to tell you they want substance
give her your life mission give her your
purpose give show her who you are and
where you are going and invite her along
on that Journey that is what attracts
women
but surely you also need to come across
as being fun you can't just do the most
boring thing in the world so how do you
balance these two
if you are talking about what is most
deeply passionate to you how could it
possibly not be fun yes if you're just
rambling on for six hours about your
stock portfolio or something like that
it's awful but if you're having an
intimate conversation with another human
being explaining that and then learning
her Mission learning her desires what
she's passionate about it should be fun
but not fun for the sake of fun it's not
masturbatory fun it is fun for a purpose
that drives education about the other
person what is the easiest way for a guy
to Broach going Beyond surface level
talk and into something a bit deeper
tell her stories that illuminate what
your life goals are that illuminate what
your values and principles are don't
tell her life stories that try to make
her impressed by who you are or make her
feel sorry for you or make her want to
jump on top of you tell her the life
stories that illuminate who you really
are as a man and where you are going and
that that right there will educate her
while also entertaining her what's the
difference between the two or could you
give us some an example yes so many men
default back to trying to explain what
they've purchased recently or they
default back to how amazing they are in
some way they try to tell stories that
pitch them as I'm better than my friends
or these are my exes this is why I left
them because I was better than them or
whatever it may be that you are trying
to elicit a certain feeling in the other
person that then makes them act a
certain way instead tell the stories
that educate them while also
entertaining them and say this is a
glimpse into Who I Really Am convenient
and inconvenient here is who I am and
here is what I'm trying to achieve those
are the pieces so you may say here is
let me tell you a story about my work
lately let me tell you a story about
this place where I volunteer let me tell
you a story about my family and you tell
that story to show her who you are
there will be a lot of women that are
listening so I would like to know if
whether you think that this is something
that guys that you go on dates with do
regularly or whether you would like them
to do it more the second one they go way
too hard with red pill and Pick Up
Artist tactics
so many guys are trying to rush through
and establish physical contact and
dominance as fast as possible and what
they're trying to do is mimic being in
love they're trying to do something
called love bombing they're trying to
make her feel wow he's really in love
with me and then it releases the same
oxytocin hormone in her that creates a
rush and makes her feel overwhelmed it's
love bombing and it is just fake and it
is not what she's actually looking for
insecure women will fall for it secure
women will shove you back and through
the door because they know what you're
trying to do and it's really
uncomfortable for them the only thing
you're going to do is Farm insecure
women which is why red pill and Pua guys
say hit on a hundred women a night and
one of them will sleep with you you are
trying to find someone who's so insecure
should lets you jump through her
boundaries and make her feel validated
one of the problems that a bunch of
friends had about 10 or 15 years ago
when the game came out first with Neil
Strauss was
they became very disenchanted with who
they were personally because they
created a Delta between the person that
their
uh evening partner was going to go home
with and the person that they really
were and that made them feel bad about
themselves they thought oh hang on so
this is how performative I have to be in
order to get a girl to go home with me
which then makes them both resent
themselves but even more so resent women
because they feel unlovable as who they
are despite the fact that they've never
shown who they are to the person that
they're talking to because that person
is inherently broken and unlovable but
that um positing an ideal version of you
or a Pua ideal version of you and
feeling the gap between where you are
and who that person is get made more of
the guys that did pick up black pill
than the guys that didn't go home with
girls
these are the guys who come into my
coaching practice with millions of
dollars in the bank and they sleep with
five different girls every week and they
say Adam I have never been more
miserable than I am right now these are
the guys who come in because they think
everything is about being fake that's
just like it goes back to Red Pill it
teaches you to be avoidant on purpose to
never find real love because Real Love
Is Impossible when you learn that that
is not true when you learn that you must
be who you are so that you can attract
someone who is attracted to you long
term that's the only way to build Puffs
and once you do that then you start
filtering for the right people next one
they play games like don't text her for
three days bro
game playing is just a way of saying I
don't trust you enough to connect with
you so I'm going to push your buttons
I'm going to manage you like a video
game and I'm going to play until I get a
win condition or until I get game over
and then I'm out of here and that's what
games are if you're playing games with
her and trying to read her mind and
trying to figure it out you've already
lost
we've got the other side of this as well
which is they're way too nice and overly
romantic
way too nice and overly romantic either
comes across as love bombing like you're
being fakes you're trying to make her
feel amazing to forget that she doesn't
actually love you yet so she'll sleep
with you or it comes across as being
eager to please Mom because you're
trying to please women the way you
pleased your mother growing up and you
don't know what women actually want from
you both are a fairly big turn off for
secure women the only people who respond
to that are avoidant women who are
looking for anxious men to snap up and
have sex with for a period of time and
then dump you and then just reconfirm
the red pill beliefs or women who are
really anxious and are ultimately
craving that approval from you and you
don't really want to connect with either
woman you want a woman who is secure and
stable who is going to give you a life
partnership Mark Manson's models says
that the number one turn off for women
is neediness what's your thoughts on
that
neediness is very different from having
needs neediness is childhood neediness
is saying I can't find Solutions I'm
going to lay here crying until someone
else solves my problem for me it is not
like most men say being a completely
immovable stone that never has a
weakness because women don't want that
either they want to see that you have
vulnerabilities and challenges that they
can help you with but they also want to
see you rising to the occasion and
solving those problems because they want
and respect a man who views Solutions
and approaches them and applies them
they assume she doesn't want to hear
from them again because she wasn't
explicitly throwing herself at him
so many guys who don't who navigate from
Red Pill into regular dating and say she
didn't try to sleep with me what's wrong
with me and they build validation based
on if she's trying to have sex with him
and women do this too if you don't
understand what real interest from a
securely attached person looks like
someone who's not rushing into the
relationship for validation if you don't
know what that looks like you think they
are uninterested or bored or boring now
you must recalibrate what actual
romantic interest looks like before you
can really pursue a healthy relationship
they try to rush to sex
rushing to sex is just going to muddy
the waters number one it's going to
flood you with feelings and her with
feelings that are not actually what's
happening it's going to convince you
that you love each other even when you
don't you don't even know each other yet
and it's going to turn off any women
that you actually would want to build a
long-term relationship with I wouldn't
uh I really do would be very interested
to get some more data around
um attachment Styles and psychological
stability correlated with whether women
have sex either on the first date or or
how many dates it would be and this
would need to be revealed rather than
stated preferences because there's a
pretty big observer effect here to
perhaps give a a different answer to the
one that actually happens
I would be very interested I I'm pretty
fascinated by the the ability of modern
culture especially a very sex positive
modern culture to perhaps reprogram or
deprogram some felt innate
predispositions that women do have when
it comes to how long they feel like they
should wait you know because if you're
around unless you come from a
particularly traditional very strong uh
values household if you are a girl that
is around a bunch of other girls and all
of those girls have a lot of casual sex
regardless of your own personality
disposition and your own values it's
going to be very difficult to not have
that impact to the way that you see
relationships
well especially if you look at it and
she says I have very little to offer
here is a really awesome man all the
other women on Earth are going to give
him sex instantly why on Earth would he
stay with me if I don't I'm gonna have
to let him do whatever he wants so that
I can try to keep him to be competitive
in the marketplace of pulling in a good
man that's a lot of women women set the
price of sex for each other and a lot of
women are racing toward the bottom
they share the wrong type of stories Mrs
man goes right back to what we talked
about is share the stories about your
family share the stories that illuminate
your good friendships share the stories
about your accomplishments without being
a pompous about it share the
stories that show her what you're
building not just what you've
accomplished in the past but what you're
building for the future share the
stories about your business that tells
you you have a business share the
stories about your best friends it tells
you you have best friends stereo share
your stories about your best friends and
how they are moral people it tells her
you spend time around moral people tell
her stories about your mother or your
sister or your family that tells her
that you value those people and you will
continue to be around them and it tells
her what you do when you're in
relationships tell her those stories
rather than stories that make her think
that you are a complete stud in the
bedroom and you have a million dollars
in the bank that's not what a stable
woman's looking for final one they don't
mention commitment at all
women are petrified Dimension commitment
men are petrified Dimension commitment
most people want it everyone's afraid to
talk about it because they think they
will be the psycho in the room what I
tell people is through my three date
method you should be dating through the
first three dates so that you can talk
about becoming an exclusive couple by
the third date and this is the system
that actually works for people who are
moving through with good secure
attachment three dates is all you really
need to build an at least exclusive
relationship I'm not talking get married
yet but to know that the other person is
the right person for you three dates and
then you begin really testing for deeper
commitment do you think that it's more
difficult in the modern world for men or
women to talk about commitment early on
[Applause]
I think that both are equally terrified
of it and I think that women are utterly
afraid of it because they think they are
never allowed to speak about it I have
women who come into my live events on
Tick Tock for example and they say Adam
it's been eight years do you think he's
ever going to think about marrying me
I say have you ever asked him well
anytime I've kind of brought up the idea
he's broken up with me for about six
weeks and then gets back together with
me and has slept with three other women
so I've learned never to even mention
commitment hmm okay most women Will May
will wait around for eight years on the
idea of maybe getting married someday so
I would say that Society definitely is
harder on women who want commitment but
if women were more open about what they
wanted they would filter out the men who
don't want it and they would attract The
Men Who absolutely do want it what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]